in germany and rapidly rising
coronavirus infections have prompted
action from the authorities the capital
berlin has joined frankfurt and cologne
on the list of cities where new cases
have exceeded a key measure
bars and restaurants have to close early
but there's
some doubt about whether the new
restrictions will be enough to stop the
spike
11 pm and it's pouring with rain but
that doesn't stop
these young people here in berlin
neither does the rise in coronavirus
infections
in the past few weeks the police have
had to clear public squares and parks
people were ignoring hygiene and social
distancing rules
now the city is cracking down
since the end of the summer holidays the
focus has shifted to young people who
got infected during leisure activities
especially in pubs people get infected
because they don't keep their distance
when it gets late
the new rules are strict no more than
five people can gather at 11 at night
private parties will be limited to 10
instead of 25
guests bars restaurants and kiosks will
also have to close between 11 p.m and 6
a.m
bartender django is frustrated
that's when the bar is running at full
swing with lots of customers around
and then to say you have to leave now
we're not allowed to serve you anymore
that's the end for us
and what happens after young people have
to leave the bars at 11 o'clock
will they actually go home yes
i'm not planning to go home at 11 i want
to live my life and enjoy it as much as
possible
those who want to drink will get their
drinks beforehand they get alcohol from
the supermarket and drink it anyway
until 5am
no matter whether the bars or clubs are
open
of course i want to go out for dinner in
the evenings and sit together
after 11 but personally i want to take
people with a higher infection risk into
consideration
i can step back the new restrictions are
set to remain in force until the end of
this month
but if infections keep rising the kerbs
could be extended
meanwhile france is struggling to
contain a drastic rise in coronavirus
cases
officials reported a record 20 000 new
infections on friday alone
the government imposed one of europe's
strictest lockdowns back in the spring
and has stepped up its testing program
but despite these efforts they weren't
able to stop the onset of a second wave
france was hit especially hard in the
spring at the beginning of the covet 19
pandemic
that's why the country ramped up tests
and is now carrying out more than one
million per week
like in this lab led by jean-jacques
he says the situation has improved
given the fact that the requests were
twice as high
we had to make sure that we could
technically carry out the number of
tests requested
today this situation is currently being
resolved
but rapid testing is not the only
solution
cases are especially high in big cities
like paris
where the density of population is very
high
this hospital in pontoise north of paris
was going through a hard time during the
first wave
eduard duvall is coordinating the
covet-19 response here
he sees another main reason for the rise
in numbers in france
the french population suffered a huge
trauma during the first wave
nevertheless with another wave we're
seeing a relative lux behaviour in
people
devos says personal responsibility is
key in fighting the virus
keeping a safe distance and meeting as
few people as possible
but since the virus is now heavily
circulating in france
the government is toughening rules in
paris for example
bars have to close down for now
and now some of the other latest
developments in the pandemic
confirmed coronavirus cases in india are
nearing 7 million but there are hopes
the rate of new infection is slowing
authorities are warning that europe's
second wave of infections has struck
well before the flu season has even
started
they point to widespread covert 19
fatigue among populations
and everywhere in poland is now because
it's now become compulsory for people to
wear masks outdoors
infections have also hit a new record
high there